being bad has never looked so good and
everyone's favorite for BK's are living
proof of that
the latest descendants three music video
doesn't disappoint it's filled with epic
dance moves
lyrics references and hidden easter eggs
watch until the end to find out
everything you missed in the good to be
bad music video next four go ashore good
to be bad starts off by revealing that
VK day is here and that the BK's will be
choosing tour new people to attend
auradon prep style of the lost is filled
with excited kids who all want to get
chosen we see them running with their
applications in hand before the camera
zooms into a newspaper on the floor the
newspapers name is troubled times and
its font mimics the one of the New York
Times magazines so does this mean that
the Isle of the Lost is modeled off of
the streets of New York we totally get
that vibe
a small but readable headline in the
paper also states that the next four go
ashore meaning that the four eligible
BK's will be leaving with a gang that
very same day where's King Ben by now we
all know that opening the barrier is a
risk which is why we originally thought
that the BK's and King Ben would only go
to the Isle once however thanks to the
latest music video we now know that they
go a minimum of two times in the
mid-eighties trailer we see King Ben and
the four vks exiting the purple limo as
the Hades tries to bring down the
barrier
however ain't good to be bad King Ben is
nowhere to be found and the PKS are
wearing different outfits so the
villains on the Isle have a minimum of
two chances to escape through the
barrier in descendants three King ven
has passed on the baton in the first
descendants film King Ben was the one
calling the shots I've decided that the
children on the Isle of the Lost be
given a chance to live here in Oregon
oddly enough King van doesn't seem to
have a say in who he gets to choose this
time around it looks like he chose to
place his trust in his girlfriend and
her friends it's up to the original four
vks to choose the next round of students
which is totally cool
maybe next year the four V case you get
chosen will be tasked with choosing the
next generation of auradon villain kids
on a side note if you love High School
Musical you'll want to stick around
until the very end we noticed a
hilarious hsm reference in the good to
be bad video and you won't want to miss
it
Jafar snake-headed staff J son of Jafar
goes off on his own to encourage the
orphaned children to fill out their
applications we see J slide down a roof
to gain access to the building and as
he's sliding we noticed that his
father's snake staff is graffiti'd on to
the orphanage roof it's obvious that
Jafar has been keeping busy ever since
Jay turned his back on the Isle but if
there's one thing we noticed it's how
poor and dingy the buildings really are
in fact one of the vks seems to be
sleeping on the roof and to make matters
worse his bed is outside yikes the aisle
is even worse than we thought a friend
to the friendless it's no secret that
Carlos is a super nice guy in fact he's
probably the nicest BK on the Isle of
the Lost and from the looks of things
his kindness hasn't gone unnoticed the
aisles or if an inch has Carlos posters
all over its walls and it's children are
over the moon with admiration for him we
see Cruella De Vil Sun danced his way
out of the orphanage in total Carlos
fashion and that's when we noticed that
the orphanage is called Carlos's house
below the sign it also says a safe place
for Lost Boys and Lost Girls we loved
this Peter Pan reference eby's Ali Evy
has always been one of the coolest V K's
on the Isle her talent beauty and wit
fashion sense have turned her into a
celebrity of sorts it looks like mal EB
Carlos and Jay will each get to choose a
VK and it's pretty obvious that easy has
chosen dizzy they do share a special
bond after all we also noticed that the
aisle named one of its alleys after EB
EB sings I want to see you all rep your
blocks while dancing her way through
Evie's alley
so if Evie chose dizzy who did now
choose the journey card mal is most
definitely going to choose Celia facili
a she approaches her while singing
today's the day that you won't forget
and Celia welcomes her with a mysterious
smiled she encourages mal to pick a card
from her tarot deck and Mao selects the
journey card this card is also known as
the fool's journey and it indicates that
mal will go on a journey to incorporate
and realize her wholeness so it's safe
to say that mal will soon embark on a
journey of self-discovery we just hope
Celia's cards don't have any hidden
factors but then again who are we
kidding she's dr. facili a's daughter
after all
Jai's choice we're pretty sure that
Carlos is going to choose a VK named bug
but what about Jay who will he choose in
the teaser video VK day is coming we see
a kid named Kazi filling out an
application he sees that Jay is his
favorite VK and during the music video
we see Jay stop a kid on a bike and Pat
his head on cause ease application it
says that his favorite pastime is
reading and we happen to see inside of
the mysterious kids backpack which is
filled with newspapers we're pretty sure
that this little VK will turn out to be
Jays choice the aisle is divided if
there's one thing we noticed throughout
the good to be bad video it's that the V
Keys have no shortage of fans this is
pretty surprising considering that few
men or pals absolutely hate the VK s the
Isle of the Lost is clearly divided a
portion of its inhabitants want revenge
while the other half want freedom and
happiness it doesn't seem fair that the
nice VK should have to stay behind as
their friends get chosen to go to
auradon prep but maybe that will all
change after the threat to Oregon is
defeated Lady Gaga and High School
Musical references fans were quick to
point out that good to be bad in high
school musicals the boys are back sound
a lot alike
and while it's no coincidence really
after all Kenny Ortega did direct both
of these movies so he was probably
referencing the old Disney franchise on
top of that the VK saying about being
born this way which is a lady Gaga
reference if we've ever seen one
and since Lady Gaga aims to spread
self-worth in acceptance it makes sense
that her touching lyrics would appear
and good to be bad so did you guys pick
up on anything that we miss let us know
in the comments section below and that's
a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if
you're excited for descendants three and
be sure to hit that subscribe button for
the latest news about your favorite
movies and TV shows thanks for watching
see ya
[Music]